hey folks i'm dan record and I am here
with Kevin vanore well one expected
collaboration look at us we yeah I know
right we kind of work together yeah sort
of in the same sometimes in the same
building even yes in Florida yes totally
now we got a table here it's it's true
we got a table and we got Dark Souls 3
to talk about that's what I want to talk
to you about you played it for about 20
minutes here at e3 well I didn't play it
I saw it play but I saw 20 minutes worth
of gameplay ok and he did talk to me as
ah he was there to sort of walk us
through and I sort of had a two-phased
reaction to what I saw the first the
first 10 minutes my reaction was sort of
oh yeah this is Dark Souls and that in
that sense because it was it was all
very familiar you know you start at the
you started the bonfire and you go out
and you start killing stuff there were
some really striking things about the
visuals at the stage as is common with
with with Dark Souls in this case it was
the sort of the faded Sun they talked a
lot about how the Sun is fading and how
that you know how that affects the
lighting and the visuals and things like
that also like corpses that looked like
they'd turn into trees and then those
trees in turn were being worshipped by
corpses so some of those kind of typical
Dark Souls you know you know medieval
dark fantasy kind of visuals so at first
it was like yeah this is Dark Souls and
then the combat began and it was still
pretty much oh this is Dark Souls they
made a big deal in this case about how
they're adding some stances and things
like that so for example you get a great
sword and now you have a different kind
of stance and then with this stance you
can pull off like these really huge
swings in this case that said Knights
flying into the air and stuff like that
looked really cool but again it looked
very much like Dark Souls specifically
the first one like I noticed you're
saying Dark Souls like is it more like
the original or you know are there
elements of two and it's it's really
hard to say when you only see twenty
minutes I would say maybe more like Dark
Souls one but the interesting thing is
that the interface was turned off so I
didn't get to see a lot of interesting
things clearly Estus flasks were in play
which was really nice and that was you
know but whether or not you know for
example you can move between bonfires
from the beginning of the game
and that kind of stuff or whether you
know enemies will stop spawning after a
while and that kind of thing they did
say that they're really fond of the
interconnectedness of the original Dark
Souls so I suspect that it's probably
going to draw more comparisons to the
original especially since the big baddie
is is this as is cinder dude I suddenly
forgot his name so at the end of Dark
Souls like that's that's basically who
you who you kill but it's but it's a
real question of whether or not
Gwyn is coming back I actually
specifically asked the question is is
Gwyn coming back or is this essentially
what the Dark Souls 1 player has become
they were all very mum on that so I
don't actually have an answer though a
lot of people did ask me on Twitter when
I when I when I talked about this the
second half of the demo was much more
interesting to me we had first of all we
had a mini-boss kind of emerge out of a
rooftop and it was cool looked very it
looked very greasy and tenderly kind of
like the tendrils you shoot out of
yourself and prototype and prototype -
it had that vibe to it and that was that
was really cool and then they finished
it off with an actual boss behind the
usual you know the usual fog door and
this boss was was meant to like sort of
be inspired by dancers was a giant night
but it was this giant night that sort of
flowed in this ballet kind of way
throughout the throughout the arena and
had sort of a spiritual veil and a
spiritual cape on and Miyazaki mentioned
that the bosses in this in this game are
meant to be harder to read so that's
that's actually really interesting and a
few other combat additions to like short
bows they're really fast to to aim and
shoot in this case which is really good
and he showed a little bit about getting
the short bow and involved with with
melee combat so looked all really fast
and fluid but apparently it's supposed
to be just as hard and I I believe that
since he died twice during the
presentation so I believe that this game
is going to be hard I believe it's
probably going to be good there was that
first half was like yeah this is Dark
Souls what's
what's what's new and interesting here
well by the time the end came I was
reminded oh yeah this is Dark Souls and
that now I'm excited again do you think
new players that just got introduced to
the series via blood-borne do you think
they'll feel at home coming into this
one well I'm similar enough
well they I expect it'll have the usual
similarities that you know that's sort
of the basic similarities but he did say
that they're working on making things a
little faster so you know for example if
you have your dual blades chances are
you'll be able to really whip through
things a lot faster than you would
before in Dark Souls so I suspect
they'll probably learn a few lessons
from blood-borne but he was not quick to
make those comparisons because of course
these are games being published by two
different publishers so sounds good man
thank you sure absolutely